i'm curious what was the first thing you
were told about this show i mean how
much did they tell you what did they
describe it as because it seems like
it's kind of a hard show to describe
yeah you're so right try doing two days
of press describing it it was um
you know it kind of has a bit of
everything but at its heart it's a
suspenseful thriller and along the way
it asks a lot of really big questions
about the truth and what is the truth
and how it can be constructed and who
buy and um you know the role social
media plays in that surveillance how it
impacts our lives your personal rights
there's a lot that goes into it
um you know
socioeconomic status and how that
impacts your life and whether it's fair
and you know there's massive topics in
there um but there's also we get to see
these very ordinary people that lives
their lives get completely turned upside
down because they're accused of a
kidnapping and then they're tasked with
clearing their name and and how that
really affects their lives and how it
could possibly destroy it um
and we get to see that all play out in
the course of eight days so it's there's
a lot going on
in terms of how i heard about the show
um i got to read the first two episodes
i got to read for the role of tara um
and
i mean as soon as i saw who was involved
i was pretty hooked with it being apple
tv plus and keshia who made brought us
homeland and false flag the israeli
series that suspicion is based on
and then rob williams the writer chris
long who was going to direct it it was
just
just i couldn't i couldn't say no and
then i read the first two scripts and i
couldn't put it down and so
yeah it wasn't like a few days later i
was in england and it was kind of we
were off
it's funny because the first two scripts
like by the time you get to the end it
feels like a very different show once
you know everything yes did you have
hints did you have to find out the rest
as you got each script or did you know
where it would all end up no we kind of
we'll
we learned as we we'd learned what we
needed to know when we needed to know it
so uh because we shot out of order we
came up with a whole new protocol of how
to film during the pandemic and um that
meant that we shot quite a lot out of
order and so we did get a few scripts
earlier than we may have otherwise got
them which was very fun but we didn't
find out
i didn't know what was happening
in the final episode till about halfway
through filming
i was shocked
yeah i would imagine
[Laughter]
when agents of shield ended did you
actively want to seek out another tv
series or were you not that specific
when you were looking for possible
projects were you just sort of open to
everything or did you want to find
you know another show like this where
you could work with another ensemble
i wasn't overly specific in the format i
guess for me it always comes down to the
script and the character and and that
could be a rom-com or a thriller or i um
i kind of know it when i read it and and
how i
how i um
how i feel like what i need to be
challenged in and then also you know
it's like the job that says yes to you i
i really wanted this job but i just
didn't think there was i i did the
audition and honestly didn't give it a
second thought because it just felt like
it was
um
just a just a dream you know and so then
when it did happen it was a really out
of body experience and for me it
happened very quickly i came in kind of
right at the end of the casting process
kind of accidentally and
and then it was very fast and it felt
very surreal um
i
i don't i don't i i only audition for
things that i love and so that's kind of
something i've always
always
stuck to whether works coming in or
isn't because
uh you know it's an investment of your
life and your time and uh this was just
such a wonderful show and i i want to
say that i fought so hard for it but i i
honestly just didn't think there was any
way i was going to book it i mean i did
my best but i didn't like
honestly didn't give it too much thought
maybe that's maybe that's what did it
are you the type of actor who gets
nervous at the start of every project do
you
not get nervous like how do you and if
you do like how do you get over those
nerves yeah you know
um
i do get nervous
i was super nervous for the for the
first couple of weeks of this because i
just it felt very fast and i think you
know your mind can play tricks on you of
like whether you deserve it or not or
whether they've made a mistake and you
kind of think they're going to tap you
on your shoulder and say i'm so sorry we
thought you were somebody else and you
know so you kind of go through all that
um but
i i enjoy nerves you know i think it
just shows that you really care about it
and it also gives you a lot of scope for
personal growth you know of going it's a
real sense of achievement when you get
home at the end of the day and you go i
did it
i can do this and and some of it is um
you know having a really supportive team
around you i think ensemble pieces are
really important to me and i love being
a part of an ensemble and so as soon as
we got in and and we all gelled very
quickly and and you know the the
times that we were filming in were
really strenuous for everybody around
the world and so to be able to to be
able to be nervous was such a privilege
because it meant that we were still
doing what we loved at a time when it
that was really rare to be able to
keep working um
so so yeah i definitely get nervous but
i also like sadistically love the nerves
you developed a very close relationship
with your agents of shield showrunners
so what was it like to
form that actor show runner relationship
on this show how did that collaboration
evolve between you and the show runner
and the directors was it a very
different feeling experience
no not really i mean it was um
i have such huge respect for them and
they're they're lovely you know and
there's there was a real collaborative
process
um
you know it was we were all going
through something extraordinary together
as much like their body of work is
incredible and and expansive but nobody
had ever shot under these circumstances
so as a result we got really close
really quickly and we were all away from
our usual
i don't want to say crutches but
comforts you know our usual way that we
get rid of nerves or you know you'll go
home and you'll be able to
give your loved one a massive hug and
that will quell the nerves none of us
kind of had those
uh methods and so then we found we
sought comfort in each other and and
and that was a really bonding experience
and i just we
we um
we just had such a a wonderful time on
set and it felt like
we were all doing something that felt
really cool and fun and
um and important as well like we all
really believe in the project so so yeah
it was um it was great and actually
there was a lot of connections with
agents of shield a lot of people chris
long one of my mentors on agents of
shield that i shadowed a bunch was a
director called nina corrado lopez and
she was chris long's um
protege so it was cool there was a lot
of connections that you know you kind of
think i'm not going to know anyone and
then
you realize the agents of shield's
network goes wide
on agents of shield you were one of the
heroes and good guys who often did
things to save the world and help people
and on this show
as we learn what's going on
your characters really are all sort of
painted as the villains or at least the
people responsible for in some way being
involved with this kidnapping
how different did it feel to play a
character like tara that's always trying
to figure out what's happening and
having to react to these things being
done to her as opposed to
someone like simmons who was more
actively involved in making things
happen
yeah gosh that's such a good question
because i feel like simmons was usually
um
you know praised for being a good girl
and then now all of a sudden i'm playing
someone that maybe those lines are
slightly blurred it was really fun
um you know i really wanted to do her
justice and i i think we've achieved in
in in everybody kind of painting these
characters that they're not all good and
they're not all bad and i think people
may draw their own conclusions as to
how morally ambiguous
they are or how if they went too far or
not far enough or because we've all made
we all make decisions in life and i
think
some of them you might not want to be
questioned on a global scale with
millions of people you know seeing your
face and and going as she did or he
didn't um
yeah i i enjoyed the ambiguity of it and
i think that we
uh we played with it on set you know we
kind of we found it in the moment as
well which which was nice
yeah there's a real fun to the show
because it feels like
you know you you're constantly wondering
could it be any one of these characters
could it be all of them could be some
pairing of them and i love when you can
find something in the characters to root
for but also be suspicious of at the
same time it's it's definitely a lot of
fun to watch in that area
totally and when we were filming it we
didn't necessarily know everything about
each other's character either so that
was
that was really fun to to to play with
and you know we each had a secret
everything that happens on this show
happens because of katherine newman and
yet
you don't really share scenes with her
so did it feel like
uma thurman was sort of off doing her
own thing practically on a whole
different show even though she was
playing such a central figure to the
story you know it's really interesting
because there's without giving too much
away there there are um
intertwining plots you know and so
for for my experience of it it was
extremely immersive with these other
group of suspects which is what tara was
going through and so
it it was it was really useful that
i was we were around each other all the
time and i think that chemistry
really helps when you get along with
people because
you know that you're spending a lot of
time together but also so are your
characters
and they're going through something
extraordinary at the same time so so
yeah it also made makes watching it
amazing because there's so much of it
that you know i didn't you're not around
for and so then you go oh my gosh wow
they she played it like that and
she's just i mean uma is
iconic and such a massive role model to
me and
um i just think she's extraordinary in
this and you know we always knew we we
knew i i knew that she would be but
there's something about seeing it that
you just go
like i i'm i'm transfixed whenever she's
on screen along with the ensemble we
also get to see your character's
relationship with her daughter so what
was that bond like to form did you guys
get to
spend any actual time together
yeah we did i got to hang out with her
and her family and i mean she's such a
brilliant actress just a powerhouse of
an actress and um yeah it was really
special because
uh i you know we kind of had a shutdown
halfway through filming we're not
halfway through filming three weeks into
filming but and and um
uh i i kind of got to
you know see her growth and i hear what
she you know she's at school and it was
like
it's just it's such a
it's such a pivotal age anyway and then
to go through something like this
and to
to
to watch her grow through that was just
an amazing experience i
absolutely loved working with her um and
she's one to watch she's incredible in
this
without spoilers once you read the
script for the final episode and learn
the final reveals and learned about what
would happen for your character
what was your reaction what were the
emotions you went through how did you
react to learning all of that
oh my gosh i was
shocked i was so shocked and the amazing
thing is is that
without giving anything away it's it's
not that there's a lot going on you know
and it's and it's complicated and it and
i think
i i think it's gonna it it's not so
black and white it's not so cut and
dried like everybody potentially is
gonna have a slightly different opinion
on
the end result
uh
as an actor
it was just the most amazing episode to
shoot and there's a particular scene
that lasts a long time
that was one of the best
things
to have been involved in and a chris
long shot that episode and it was it's
something i'll take with me forever
because it was just
so dramatic
so many twists and turns so many amazing
beats to play and
yeah i i've never experienced anything
like it and i think it's it's a payoff
that by the time we get to that eighth
episode
i think as a show we've really earned
and so they're always the you know the
most delicious moments
yeah shows like this for me always sort
of rely on on how it all ends up and
yeah it keeps you on your toes i love
that so thank you for talking to me
about it oh gosh of course
you